welcome back to the sixth episode of
deep mind the podcast my name is Hanna
Frey I am a mathematician who's worked
with data and algorithms for the last
decade or so and I spent the last year
at deep mind an organization that is
trying to solve intelligence and then
use it to solve some of society's
problems there are an awful lot of
people working in the field of
artificial intelligence moving forward
our understanding of the whole area and
for many of them is a terrifically
exciting place to be with breaking new
frontiers of problem solving and seeing
great leaps ahead but before any of that
hits the outside world the first
Inklings of me breakthroughs here at
deep mind come in the form of regular
poster sessions have a Marla can carry
out the following simple tasks where I'm
gonna give you a number and a secret
symbol and what the sum between those
two are and you have to infer from that
what the values but it requires our
agents to have some properties that we
think are desirable like learning to
learn having a memory and processing
those memories
we're studying analogical reasoning and
logical reasoning is very important
because it's key to scientific discovery
also human reasoning the main question
we ask is how can we design your own
networks that are able to do our logic
to be single my poster is about
verification of neural networks in this
day and age when we deploy in your
networks into the real-world
applications we want to make sure that
these newer networks are safe for
example if you have an image classifier
we don't ever want to predict the cat to
be like a car with something like that I
always say deep mind is a bit like
academia on steroids okay it's still
like an emu but we have a lot of compute
a lot of great people clustered together
a lot of help to like manage ourselves
so while there is obvious excitement
about AI research this new era of
artificial intelligence also comes with
concerns there is unease about the way
it might be implemented used and abused
for the rest of this episode we are
looking at the more human side of
technology and the fight to find a
future of AI that works for everyone in
2017 deepmind set up dedicated teams
working on how AI impacts ethics and
society with the aim of making sure that
the algorithms designed in this building
a positive force for good bang on I know
you're thinking surely algorithms aren't
ever good or bad in and of themselves
it's how they used that matters after
all GPS was invented to launch nuclear
missiles and now helps to deliver pizzas
and speakers playing pop music on repeat
have been deployed as a torture device
isn't the technology itself just neutral
good question and I think something a
lot of people say and believe and I can
see why they say that this is Verity
Harding co-lead of deep mind ethics and
society I hit let's earth famous saying
about as long as there's been fire
there's been arson but you can use
something that's for good you can use it
for bad but I think actually as we're
developing increasingly so
stated technologies that have real
impact on people's lives it's not really
an acceptable thing to say you can't be
building something that's going to have
this kind of monumental impact or
potentially transformative impact and
not care about how it's going to be used
it's that part of a concern then the
technology that might have been built
for one purpose ends up being used in a
different way I think definitely that's
some of it I think definitely that's
some of it because you could foresee a
situation where you're building a facial
recognition tool because you want to
allow somebody to quickly find pictures
of their husband or wife or mom or dad
and that's a great thing
but that facial recognition technology
once developed could of course be used
to target political dissidents and pick
them out of a crowd you know and so I
think that is definitely one of the
concerns that you might create something
for one purpose and it be used for
another on the topic of facial
recognition Brad Smith the president of
microsoft recently refused a request by
a US police department to install their
algorithm in cop cars and body cameras
and he's publicly called for more
careful thought and societal dialogue
about potentially regulating the use of
the technology and here at deep mind
more generally there is a strong sense
that the people behind the science have
a duty to investigate the wider and
perhaps less predictable impacts of
their work I don't think it's okay to
build something whether that be a
product or a service and put it out
there and and just just hope that you
make the world a better place I think
it's important that you are deliberate
and intentional about why you're
building this who are you building it
for what are you hoping to do what is
your intention with this technology and
if you start from that premise then I
think you're more likely to get to a
better outcome where you do the good
that you hoped you were going to do the
problem is that without these steps it
is very easy for unintentional
consequences to creep up on you you only
need to look at the news stories about
social media from the past
two years to see just how much
algorithms have changed our society in
unexpected ways Lila Abraham is deepmind
CEO and has over 20 years experience
working in the tech sector she has seen
firsthand how hard a booming industry
has found it to keep up with being
responsible in 2006 I went into the
middle of the Amazon and we built a
computer lab and health care so we put
in Internet and computers etc we knew we
had a responsibility not to just leave
it there but to Train folks to take care
of it to think about the sustainability
but I think that's kind of where things
tend to end epochs means something very
different now and responsibility means
something very different now because
technology is in everybody's hands it's
no longer limited to a few people for a
specific application it's a lot easier
to get into the tech sector and to make
technology that can have value to people
and at the same time that comes a lot of
responsibility that I don't think in
general the tech sector has taken into
account but the last few years have
shown how hugely transformative and
disruptive AI can be and brought sharply
into focus the very possible negative
outcomes of ill thought through
technology
but as Verity told me the tide is slowly
beginning to turn much of the drive for
a conversation about ethics is coming
from within the technology community
itself three years ago in 2016
some of the scientists from different
labs at different companies met at a
conference and we're talking about how
excited they were about the potential
for AI to do a lot of good but
acknowledging that a technology that's
so powerful that it has the potential to
be transformative in a very good way
must also have the potential to be
transformative in in not-so-good away
and so they came together to say well
what can we do about it and so the
partnership on AI was born it includes
members from Amnesty International
Electronic Frontier Foundation the BBC
and print
ten university amongst many many others
and together they're hoping to come up
with best practices in AI making sure
that society stays firmly at the
forefront of engineers minds so the
partnership on AI interestingly was
founded by the biggest tech companies so
it was founded by deep mind but also
Google Facebook Amazon IBM and Apple one
thing that's really interesting about
the partnership in AI is that the board
membership is made up of independent
board members and representatives of the
company and so it's creating a space
where those different groups aren't
siloed from each other having debates in
different rooms and not listening but
somewhere where honest people with the
best of intentions can come together and
challenge each other and scrutinize each
other and hold each other accountable
but also have Frank open honest debate
about issues where reasonable people can
disagree I really believe that the
outcome of that will be better
decision-making both in companies but
but elsewhere as well because it
sometimes get quite heated in those
conversations you know my experience of
it is that it doesn't get heated it but
it's passionate so people aren't angry
with each other and there's there's not
aggressive argument but people are very
honest I'm very open and very
challenging but that's been received
really well in in all cases how do you
protect against rogue companies just who
are not a part of these groups just
doing whatever they want if enough
companies and enough groups sign up to
something and it becomes the norm its
then really obvious when people aren't
doing it and I do think people being
kind of cooled out for that it'll no
longer be tenable to not operate in the
way that everybody else is operating
it's not just theoretical concerns about
runaway applications of AI that's
prompting these conversations but real
examples of algorithms that have already
been let loose on the world with real
question marks about whether their
benefits outweigh their harm a notorious
example is the use of AI in the criminal
justice system now you may have heard of
these algorithms already
when a defendant appears in court the AI
can assess a defendant's chances of
going on to commit another crime in
future and that risk score is then used
by a judge to help decide whether the
defendant should be awarded bail and in
some cases how long someone's sentence
should be there is good justification
for something like this because there is
an enormous amount of luck involved in
the human judicial system studies have
shown that if you take the same case to
a different judge you will often get a
different response if you take the same
case to the same judge on a different
day you'll often get a different
response judges don't like giving the
same response too many times in a row
and so if a series of successful cases
of bail hearings have gone before you
your chances of being successful fall
and there is even evidence to suggest
that judges tend to be a lot stricter in
towns where the local sports team has
lost recently using AI to help make
these decisions can help to eliminate a
lot of that inconsistency but you have
to tread pretty carefully if you without
thought and care and due attention to
the history of racial prejudice in the
criminal justice system build something
that claims to be able to predict
somebody's likelihood of reform and
rehabilitation and reoffending then it
is likely at least in my view that
that's going to fail if you build
something with the intention of
addressing those biases and you work to
include the community in some way you
could there potentially be a beneficial
outcome maybe but I haven't seen it yet
and by fail you're really talking about
treating black defendants differently to
white defendants absolutely and once you
tend to look at the algorithms and the
data that they've been they've been
built on oftentimes you can see whether
they were built on data that was already
biased so of course this was the outcome
the issue came to public attention in
2016 after a group of US investigative
journalist from ProPublica published a
damning report of one particular
company's criminal risk scores their
study showed that the algorithm was
twice as likely to wrongly categorize
black defendants as being likely to
reoffend than white defendants now I
should just point out that deepmind does
not build these systems but the whole
industry alongside the partnership in AI
has been part of the conversation of how
to address them one of those people is
William Isaac a social scientist at deep
mind he says that the 2016 Pro Publica
investigation made people realize that
switching over to algorithms doesn't
make decisions any more objective even
with AI and ML tools you are getting
into the social environment where you
actually have the same norm the same
kind of like systemic biases they're
still all present so it's really hard to
say that somehow this will replace all
of the kind of subjective preconceived
notions about certain groups or
historical biases against them and that
you can start all over again and so I
think that was the wake-up call was that
is not as objective as it seems and that
as a result we still have to grapple
with those questions the problem is the
data which gives the algorithm
predictive abilities a questions like
how many times were you arrested as a
juvenile but if you are say a young
black man in America it doesn't matter
how Laura biting you are the chances are
that you will have had many more
negative interactions with the police
then someone exactly like you who
happened to be white and if you're using
that data to dictate who deserves to be
given bail or not then you
and serious risk of perpetuating
societal imbalances going forwards this
is Silvia Chiappa a staff research
scientist at deep mind research don't
fully understand what this furnace is
about they also look like a messy area
in the sense that involves it is not
purely technical problem and it's very
difficult to understand what how to
define fairness and it's difficult to
separate the technical part from the
ethical one this is an important point
because defining exactly what you mean
by fair is surprisingly tricky
of course you'd want an algorithm that
makes equally accurate predictions for
black and white defendants the algorithm
should also be equally good at picking
out the defendants who are likely to
reoffend whatever racial group they
belong to and as ProPublica pointed out
the algorithm should make the same kind
of mistakes at the same rate for
everyone regardless of race ethically
you'd want all of those things to be
true but technically that's not always
going to be possible if your data set
has bias in it there are some kinds of
fairness that are mathematically
incompatible with others and even if you
could guarantee all of these things
there are still a number of ethical
issues to contend with how do you
measure fairness who is excluded from
your definition how do you make those
decisions transparent and ultimately how
do people contest the decisions made by
those algorithms see I told you it was
tricky coming at this from two very
different perspectives William and
Silvia started looking into the bigger
issue of fairness in algorithms even
though we had kind of different
frameworks me as a social scientists and
Silvia is a machine learning researcher
the actual overlap between how we would
approach this and basically the
assumptions that are embedded within it
were remarkably similar and actually
part of us was saying like oh like look
at these papers and social science that
are kind of making the same point they
just hadn't actually had a way to
actually communicate that formally
you're listening to a podcast from the
people at deep mind in April 2009 teen
William and Sylvia Co published a paper
on fairness in AI entitled a causal
Bayesian networks viewpoint on fairness
in it they show that no matter how fair
algorithms might be if the data they're
learning from is biased we still can't
trust their results I don't think it is
possible to find technical solutions
that are completely satisfactory at some
point we need to take decisions whether
the kind of unfairness is acceptable or
not but we can't advance a lot and
that's why we need more researchers
involved and not just machine learning
researcher person researcher from
different community to be raising
awareness about this this problem find
solutions but as we will never be able
to find completely satisfactory a
solution from a technical viewpoint at
that point we need to take decision this
is important to talk about these such
that we are something that is missing at
the moment I do think this is
fundamentally like a societal ethical
question and challenge and it will
require lots of stakeholders to address
if you have let's say data set a facial
recognition tool that's designed to find
missing children
what threshold do you set as a society
where you say ok this is acceptable we
maybe are less successful at identifying
children with darker faces
what threshold do we say that's
acceptable because that's not a
technical question that's a social and
political question and a normative
question even if you do have a
classifier or facial recognition
software that's fair the application of
it may be in unfair ways and so that
might present a second question that is
separate from the actual kind of like if
you decide on the threshold right if
you're just using it in neighborhoods
that are predominantly one group or one
ethnicity that presents a whole nother
set of challenges for whether or not
that's an ethical use of a particular
technology
you can't assess whether these
algorithms are good or bad in isolation
they don't exist on there
you have to place them in the context of
the world that they're being used like
the criminal justice system or in health
care
here's Verity Harding again this is what
I mean by it being a kind of much bigger
discussion that potentially the use of
algorithms is highlighting my fear is
that people will kind of get a checkmark
that says we've tested and this
algorithm isn't biased and therefore you
should feel free to use it and that to
me isn't going far enough I think there
needs to be a further discussion then
about but is this making those decisions
that were already bad worse or more
quickly and therefore more of them and
you know that that kind of thing but
things are changing
he's William on what has happened since
that ProPublica story broke they're
going back and reconsidering what
measures they collect right and going
back and trying to create more robust
data sets thinking about who is
collecting the actual data itself will
it be ever perfect where we have bias
free purely pure data no I don't think
that that's that something is ever gonna
happen but I do think that people will
be skeptical when people ask about what
datasets are used and they don't get a
satisfactory answer right I do think
people will ask is this data set
representative does it have balance
across different groups so people will
start asking the right questions and
interrogating datasets and in models
more aggressively and I think that will
lead to better outcomes and crucially
more people are now being included as
part of the conversation in the
aftermath of some of my work and among
many others on predictive policing many
cities in California actually started
implementing citizen boards so when
police departments wanted to acquire a
new police technology that included uses
of machine learning or artificial
intelligence that they had to go in
front of a citizen board and actually
have the the local community evaluate
the tool for different metrics including
fairness and bias
[Music]
getting different voices involved in the
conversation is essential to making sure
that we build a future that belongs to
all of us because what seems obvious to
one person just wouldn't occur to
another your perspective is hard-coded
into the work that you create there are
clear examples of this everywhere
outside of AI able-bodied people
designing buildings that disabled people
can't use or new tights and plasters
that only work if your skin is one
particular color presumably the same as
the designers and the algorithms that
we've created they're really
highlighting this issue like the ones
used to automatically screen CVS and
predict which candidates will fit best
in a company here's Verity Harding again
if it's based on historically
discriminatory hiring decisions by
either intentionally or unintentionally
bias humans then it's going to kind of
recreate those those patterns like if
you've got a company where white men
have succeeded yeah and they're looking
for candidates he'll succeed it's going
to pick out white male series yes
exactly and if the people building the
technology are all white males as well
then the likelihood of paying attention
to that potential bias and being aware
of area we all have our blind spots then
the likelihood increases we've seen
driverless cars that don't spot
pedestrians with darker skin tones tumor
screening algorithms that aren't as
effective patients with ethnicities
other than white European and lots and
lots and lots of issues around gender
all of this is kind of inevitable unless
you have a range of different viewpoints
in your design process the most
important thing in my point of view for
ensuring that these things are if not
not biased but that you're being
intentional about what you're building
and aware of the potential bias is that
your team is a diverse team is that you
have a broad set of voices involved and
it's actually much simpler to do that
than
it's suggested and the issue of gender
diversity has been a particular focus of
late I think there's plenty of young
women and girls who are really excited
by science and STEM subjects and it's an
easy get out to say that there aren't
enough women in stem and that's why
workforces aren't diverse but actually
it's much more about making sure that
it's a safe space for women and girls to
work that they're not discriminated
against once they're there that you're
able to not just attract and hire them
but that you're able to keep them and
make sure that it's a place where they
feel comfortable working and so I think
it's much more important that we look at
how women are treated in science than
just dismiss it as something that girls
aren't interested in a young age Linna
abraham deepmind CEO is very conscious
that diversity is still a problem in the
tech sector as a whole talk about things
that keep me up at night right so here I
am a professional of 25 plus years with
an engineering background a mom also
raising nine-year-old twin daughters I
would have hoped by now we would have
solved the problem and yet we haven't
we're like at the same numbers are flat
but they're all steps being taken to
address it there's the short term stuff
you can do which are things like you
diversify your candidate pools you if
you're doing university recruiting you
look at a broad range of universities
and ones that have that have a broader
student representation and have support
structures often in place to help the
students through their academic and
communities you look at job descriptions
and ensure that you don't have
unconscious bias reflected and your job
descriptions you so once you're in the
recruiting pipeline then you may need to
make sure candidates have the right
experience we are being very deliberate
about how we invest back in education
ai is something that will change future
generations so how do we make this a
field that's more accessible so for
example whether its funding diversity
scholars and universities or funding AI
chairs and universities to
to increase the pipeline and I think
that helps fuel some of the academic
aspects as well as support our like
long-term recruiting this isn't just
tokenism that we're talking about here
this is about making better technology
diversity and diverse perspectives will
create a GI faster and safer and with
just a better a better result because
one of the things I worry about is how
do we avoid our own internal bias a lot
of the work around deep reinforcement
learning started from specific pockets
and many people grew up in those labs or
those universities and you know we they
brought their former colleagues and so
we have a pretty strong network of
people that have known each other for a
long time
which is fantastic and they can really
advance certain aspects of our of our
work and yet there are other areas that
are emerging how do you teach curiosity
how do you how do we ensure that we
minimize bias and the code that we're
writing who's to say what intelligence
is and isn't unless you have a better
representation from society and that's
just on the research side on the
operation side to you think about things
like okay think about public policy like
if you're asking governments to think
about how they're going to treat
artificial intelligence then you want
people that are representative of the
the constituents of the population if we
want to be focused on education making
sure that we're not just focused on the
specific schools but our broader range
so we're bringing more people into this
space I just think it's going to be
imperative for us to truly solve
intelligence that we're just going to
need to have more diversity so he's
positive that well solution is probably
a bit grand their words to suggest but
it is part of the way forward making
ethics a kind of keystone every stage of
the process rather than having is an
afterthought oh absolutely we have to be
thinking about our responsibility for
the technology we develop and to
candidly to
as a whole every step along the way and
I think that there's something quite
special about being Pittock ordered out
of London versus being based out of
Silicon Valley
I'd love Silicon Valley it's where my
career has has really developed and yet
you're surrounded by technologists you
know from the billboard signs to the
marketing and promotion here in London
it's so multicultural and I feel like
it's part of your daily life you need to
be thinking about the work that you're
doing and how it is going to impact all
the people around you but of course we
can't just leave the solution solely in
the hands of the people who are
designing these things it's our future
to the public and government should also
have a hand in this my impression is
that people want to understand what
they're using and want to understand
what makes it work and how it works but
they more importantly want their
representatives and the people tasked
with keeping them safe and secure to
understand it too and I think that's why
we've seen a bit of a breakdown in
recent times if you want to know more
about ethics diversity and fairness then
head over to the show notes where you
can also explore the world of AI
research beyond deep mind and we'd
welcome your feedback or your questions
on any aspects of artificial
intelligence that we're covering in this
series so if you want in the discussion
or point us to stories or resources that
you think other listeners would find
helpful then please let us know you can
message us on Twitter or you can email
us podcast at deep mind calm
you
[Music]